I'm gonna accept the minutes of May 10th
and the second any additions deletions
or corrections to the minutes
seeing done all in favor
aye aye any opposed
status
well good morning for the records Steve
Smith uh director of audits for LBA
just to give the committee a quick
update of ongoing and audits since our
last meeting
um
the uh we issued a report or not really
a report or more of a letter on the
retirement system Healthcare subsidy
that went out on dated May 23rd so that
went to legislative leadership
and at this point no further actions
happening on that
on the dental examiners further action
need to be taken
uh
there I think it was really we just
outlined the issues as we saw it and
legislature would have to
there were some
Clarity I think that could be given to
to the to the laws as I recall statute
so but it's really up to the legislature
um with the board of General examiners
we've finalized that that audit uh that
will be going to fiscal next Friday
and some of you if your server on fiscal
might be getting it today
just to alert the committee it's it's
another large report so you have plenty
of holiday reading
um it's in excess of 300 pages with
dependencies there's 36 observations in
total and I just want to remind the
committee that part of the reason why
it's a large report is that it does
really reach into some of the inner
workings of oplc so you do have a
potential topic that has been brought up
before regarding oplc
I think this report this report will
speak to a lot of the issues that the
committee may have had
but um
there's about 10 I believe observations
that that relate to uh that involve oplc
and there's at least three that are
directly to oplc only so so just to make
the committee aware of that
the mental health Workforce audit that's
ongoing we're in the middle of field
work
um
I think maybe by we're wrapping up field
work middle of next month
and again because this involves a number
of different boards and commissions once
we get into the observation and getting
response to some observation that could
be strung out a little bit because of
the meeting schedules of the of those
particular boards and committees
uh weatherization uh State sure before
we go on could we go back to the board
of dental examiners
um you had mentioned that there were
several write-ups against the oplc
is this do you think true of other
boards or do you think they're what they
have
what you've put in the audit is just
strictly for the dental no no I believe
that
um and Jay you can correct me from but I
believe it's it's the structure of oplc
a lot of the recommendations would would
feed into other boards of commissions
it's Central to whether their management
structure
uh their processes
some of the history of of what's gone on
at oplc and obviously
directly related to the board of dentals
but I think that that given what they do
a lot of what we've found will be
applicable to and apply to
pretty much everything that they do so
is there a need for restructure over
there or is it a Manpower issue or is it
well I I don't you know
I I I hesitate to get into any detail
here because we haven't presented at the
fiscal at this point in time that's when
technically the reports become public uh
okay you know what I mean so
um
but but I think there there is a variety
of those types of things are in there
thank you
um
on the weatherization assistance
it's a small operation over there
there's really a one-man shot we did we
get we did get started but they had a uh
a previously scheduled Federal audit
that they had to deal with
they also received a lot of new money
that they had to kind of work through
the the process of getting that
distributed and and controls and
everything around that we also had some
turnover on our side so
um things are stolen things are still
moving just slowly right now but I think
that they will pick up and um
hopefully I think we'll be able to we
have a few observations that we've
identified so maybe
February March time frame for
finalization and a report on that one
on the special education dispute
resolution process we're doing field
work
um
one of the things we wanted to do to get
access to users of the dispute
resolution processes we needed to obtain
email addresses and information from the
local school districts we received a
little I'll say pushback but a
hesitation as to whether they had the
authority to do that to release that
information so we had to work through
some federal contacts and long and short
of it is is we can do it and local
um something like an email address to us
so we can reach out and and and do a
survey it's not considered a student's
education record per say it's just
contact information so
um so that that's ongoing so we're
making progress there
and then in terms of the much broader
special education audit we're in now
that we're wrapping up Dental we're
starting to move on to that and so we're
in the planning stages of that and
developing a scope State well we already
have the scope statement approved so
and then the only other one that's in
our queue is the education Freedom
account but that won't occur until fall
of 2023 or over a year from now so
any questions that's kind of a quick
recap status of our ongoing audits uh
just a quick question on the education
Freedom account uh audit
um
looking at 2023 is that because of your
Workforce or
um I think that was uh
there was some when the when the statue
was the way the bill was being developed
there was some
how much information would be available
because it's a new program to be able to
be assessed and to be able to to look
and I think the the earliest
was our fall of 2023 to have something
that could be audited really
as well as enough activity to to
foreign
really what we need is we need we'd like
to get at least one topic to move
forward forward with so
can you suggesting the ones that were
here and we also have
representative representative here to
okay one or both of you tell us what you
want
good morning Mr chair morning members of
the committee for the record uh my name
is representative McLean uh representing
Hillsboro 44 which is Manchester and
Litchfield and I was the chair and
interim study committee on the Human
Rights Commission and with me is
representative Marjorie Smith of Durham
and so
um we had a bill come before us in
judiciary last year SB 296 the purpose
of the bill was pretty straightforward
it wanted to take away the right of
removal from the Human Rights Commission
to the Superior Courts to the
respondents and Reserve that right
exclusively for the claimants and
constitutionally legally that was sound
only two states allow removal by the
respondent the only reason that we we
held that over for interim study was
because if you take away the right of
removal that means those are going to be
staying at the Human Rights Commission
and where they had a backlog we just
wanted to understand what impact that
would have expand on a writer removal so
the right of removal is when you take
the case to the Human Rights Commission
the claimant has a choice as to where to
take the case they can go either to the
superior court or the Human Rights
Commission after 180 days the claimant
may choose to take the case and remove
it to the superior court but the
respondent after a finding of probable
cause can also remove the case to the
superior court and the reason that the
bill was brought for us was they said
look you you've spent all this time your
come to the the five yard line and then
you pull it to a different form it's
just not fair and that is why 48 other
states don't allow it and the Supreme
Court has struck it down for their
challenged here it would be struck down
as well so constitutionally we had no
issues with the bill I just wanted to
understand the impact of removing the
right of removal how it would impact the
workload at the Human Rights Commission
and that really was the major focus of
the interim study
committee
what we found was that there is a
significant backlog at the Human Rights
Commission the statutory requirement is
that you basically put through people
through the process and there's a
two-year statutory limit now for the 80
percent of the lifespan of the
commission that statutory limit was one
year but ten years ago there were cuts
to the resources at the commission and
so it was moved out to two years in
recognition of what those cuts were but
we heard in testimony that not only are
we not meeting that two-year statutory
limit we're going out in cases to five
years you know and as chairman Gordon
the chair of our committee said Justice
delayed is Justice denied and so when we
got in the Human Rights Commission is
unique because there's a huge
investigatory arm and the pro process
really starts when an investigator is
assigned that's not happening on the
Human Rights Commission right now for 18
months so it it really is dragging out
they're out of place right now where the
they are docketing 25 new cases a month
and they're able to get through the 25
cases so it appears right now that
they're achieving a sort of steady state
but with a high turnover rate what
happens is they lose people and the
backlog goes up and the backlog right
now is at 300 cases okay and so that
backlog is really staying flat except
when they go through more turnover and
then it ratchets up it ratchets up it
never comes down see we have a motion on
a second
okay
all those in favor hi
okay Senator you didn't even want to
hear
it's okay
did you want to add
wait work with the
right
thank you very much okay Senator could
could I also ask
I know that we've got oplc and
certification as a tabled item
and
hearing from
what was just said about the Dental
examiner's Board
I I firmly believe that we need to
pursue that
uh but that's
concerned about the table the item for
oplc
um
and you'll probably be able to get it
today you'll have it for a physical next
week and certainly be able to ask a lot
of questions at that meeting
um I think as uh Steve Smith said it
does cover
a lot of information a lot of the topics
between the board being born and the
oatmeal State and I think it will have a
lot of if there's 50 of the boards oh
right right the same I think you're
going to find the same issues throughout
the whole organization
if I might okay so what you're
suggesting is that at this time
uh we don't take this off the table
but rather I mean it'll looking at what
you've got going on
uh this probably wouldn't
have uh
be able to be audited until sometime
trying to address
don't find it I mean some of the
observations some of the recommendations
are you know will take longer than a
they have a bunch of things they're
going to have to work on to begin with
um
from what I understand the emergency
he was everything's available okay
that's fine I accept your position thank
you
and does somebody want to comment on the
foreign
you have a letter from Mike Kane to to
you the committee and then the
Senator Reagan as chair of this
committee will we have a letter for him
to sign to go to the fiscal committee
but it's just alerting you that uh when
we have of this National ncsl
um
program evaluation society that you can
submit an audit report
qualifications in particular that the
audit report was a catalyst of change
legislative change things of that nature
so we thought the adult parole board was
a would be a good candidate and we've
actually how many years now three
we've submitted three reports
for this award
this one's the fourth
so um so just just making you aware that
we submitted it and they recognize it as
meeting all the the criteria so it's one
benefit or kudos to our staff who put in
all the labor and effort in these in
these things to be recognized at a
national level so
thank you
so you said that you have a letter for
Senator Reagan to sign that will come to
fiscal yes next Friday and then this
will same thing yeah a difficult
I'm sorry
who's going to sign this letter
that comes to fiscal will it be Senator
Reagan will because it's coming from the
committee to to the fiscal committee
okay
okay the next meeting will be at the
call of the chair any other
and I I think we should recognize the
senator for his years of service on this
uh on this committee and uh this is
probably one of the uh
least exciting committees did I say that
no I'm I guess suited to it because I
thought it was exciting oh okay
oh okay
audits audits are never exciting when
they say I'm here to help
um
so uh I I think we all need to uh
recognize his dedication and uh and the
things that he's done for the committee
thank you thank you so with that the
meeting is adjourned